hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging so here is a clip of someone on
MSNBC saying something completely insane
I think this is the proof of of why the
bubble is dangerous right like
Republicans they all just listen to Fox
News they read the Daily Caller or
whatever and they they come to believe
that the vast majority of Americans want
to ban abortion want to bad drag shows
want to ban trans kids like they they
cook themselves into a pot that they
can't climb out of now and on abortion
it should have been perfectly obvious to
them all the polling has been very clear
the majority of Americans even a pretty
big plurality of Republicans do not want
abortion to be illegal but rather than
learn from the whipping they got after
their tailor-made Supreme Court got rid
of Roe v Wade and the drubbing that
everyone should have been able to see
they were going to take when you take
half of the country's rights away from
them and turn them into essentially womb
slaves of any Red State yeah you're
going to lose and yeah they lost